this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Monday the 10th of
October the joint is brought to you by
DraftKings an official sports betting
partner of the NFL the NFL is big
college is Big the playoffs major league
baseball player some big but we're
taking touchdowns big plays and even
bigger wins new customers this week
you're gonna bet five dollars in the NFL
team and win your 203 bets when the team
comes in everyone can boost their
winnings with DraftKings stepped up same
game ballets listen you know I love this
week on Monday night tonight I like the
over on Kansas City Las Vegas if you
pick the [__] team put it together
and to make things sweeter you can throw
down a stepped up same game parlay once
per day all season long download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app today use
promo code Joey to get 200 in free bets
listen you [__] around with all these
mediocre sites now come to the best with
the best prop bets available that's code
Joey only at DraftKings an official
sports betting partner of the NFL
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
download DraftKings Sportsbook Apple
better yet download the DraftKings
fantasy app put code Joey in there and
let's win some [__] cash the joint is
also brought to you by bluetooth listen
there's nothing scarier than your dick
[__] just laying there limp Bluetooth
is here to make sure your dick is giving
out trick with treats with no tricks
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis but in a chewable
tablet or
at a fraction of the cause take them
anytime and be ready whenever the
opportunity arises listen
I don't have that dick but from time to
time it takes the horse a little while
to wake up why take that chance pop a
little Bluetooth get the party started
and put a smile on Mama's face the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of the
licensed medical providers once you're
approved you receive your prescription
in days the best part is it's all done
online you don't have to go to the
doctor's office you have to go to a
pharmacy no [__] up conversations
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USFA
and shipped discreetly to you in a
package that nobody will know so if you
can book benefit from extra confidence
when it comes time to get down Bluetooth
can help try Bluetooth for free
free on a Monday morning using promo
code Joey just pay five dollars for
shipping bluetooth.com with Coach Joey
for your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more information
safety information thank Bluetooth for
sponsoring The Joint let's get this
party started it's Monday morning I got
time to [__] around
[Music]
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's going on you bad [__]
it's Monday 10 10 the 10th of the
[__] month already October I don't
know if you guys remember or not
my [__] this is the this is the
anniversary of my career [__] taking
off it was uh Felicia and I did a show
at uh someplace on [__] like I can't
remember the name of it
and we did 10 10 10
that was October 10th of 2010. this was
before Lee came on the scene we went
down there and uh it was a great [__]
show so I'll never forget that and it
won't happen again like the 10 10
whatever who gives a [__] it's Monday
[__] I'm ready for a great
[__] week I got a lot of [__] going
on this week the show at Sony Hall was
great last night or Saturday night I did
mediocre my new bits work thank [__]
god at least they were in the ballpark
uh and that's always great but I got to
come up with some more [__] Kim condom
was great Sarah weinchuk was great Lee
was [__]
really good last night to the point
where I was sitting there listening to
him and actually had to get up and go to
the corner of the stage and watch him
and it was very [__] impressive to
see like I I came home last night and
usually after a show I'm wired I didn't
fall asleep till [__] four in the
morning Saturday night
I couldn't stop thinking you just get
home so wired you know you see so many
things and your mind processing them
especially in a venue like that there's
a lot of [__] people going on a lot
of people there A lot of I saw some
friends of mine from high school and you
know it was just
it's a lot to [__]
put together while you're there but when
I get home at night I usually uh lee
came over watching TV he left we watched
The Honeymooners till like 12 30 with my
daughter and then everybody went to bed
and I just uh made some notes of my
material I listened to the set a little
bit and uh but Lee stood in my mind
because
it's [__] crazy how if you're around
something
just being around something
like somebody told me one time if you're
hurt
at least go to jiu jitsu once a week and
sit on the side and watch so you're
still in the game you know one of the
biggest things I ever took from Gene
Hackman I love Gene Hackman as an actor
I don't know if you guys know Gene
Hackman even is he was in The French
Connection a bunch of great movies
but Gene Hackman said some he goes you
know most movie people film actors uh
when they're shooting a movie they
[__] go on that trailer and they hide
not Gene Hackman Gene Hackman goes I
would always sit in the sideline just to
watch and I took that from Gene Hackman
and I started doing that paying
attention and I realized how much better
I got I saw actors that would get to a
set
say hello go to wardrobe and then
disappear and hide and then when they
call them they come out like what's
going on I didn't know no as soon as I
[__] get on a movie set
even if I'm not shooting that day I'll
go to makeup pick up my clothes whatever
the [__] they need and I'll sit there
and I'll watch and I'll listen whether
it's [__] LL Cool J John burntall or
whether it's two [__] actors you've
never heard of because I'm going to
learn something I know this
because I'm older but when you're young
you don't know these things
and seeing Lee I'll make a comparison to
Lee the biggest comparison to Lee I
could make is Eleanor Kerrigan
Eleanor Kerrigan worked at the store for
15 years as a waitress
listening watching when I met Eleanor we
had tons of conversations
out of the conversation to me about
[__] doing copy never in all that
time Eleanor Carrigan [__] was just a
hard-working girl but I still remember
her like in 2004
2005 at the store Ellen uh Ellen Eleanor
would give you
pretty good advice like if you were
talking to two comics about a situation
you had and Eleanor came over and you
were talking even as a waitress because
of what she learned from Mitzi
she would come over and she could
interject in the conversation and go hey
man I think you should do this and this
and this I looked at I don't know a
couple times I even told my wife I'm
like I don't know it's the comedy game
exactly she was a [__] waitress at
the world's best comedy club in the
[__] world when Mitzi was still
thicken so she was listening the whole
time she would sit next to Mitzi on a
Sunday night in the [__] original
room when Mitzi was showcasing people so
she got the lesson she got to learn what
the [__] Mitzi was looking for Eleanor
was a waitress but that [__] still goes
into your mind you're worried about
slinging drinks but that still goes in
your mind all those years of
of podcasting for Lee I mean think about
this
Lee sat in that room
for years and this is when we had our
own office and we had couches and when
people would come in they'd sit you know
the podcast was supposed to start at one
we wouldn't start the podcast till 2 30.
and then the podcast was supposed to end
at four and we'd be in there till seven
talking comedy with the comedian or if
it was an agent or whatever the [__] so
Lee being around that listening
that went into his [__] psyche not
that he was thinking about it he was
probably thinking of editing a podcast
or how he's going to deal with the 2 000
milligrams of Edibles he ate that
[__] day but even in that [__]
condition
he was listening and while I was
watching him I could see little things
you know and it's I tell people all the
time
we're always in a rush
as human beings we're always in a rush
and listen
I get it
I [__] get it I was one of those
human beings that
when you're involved in something you
want it to happen to have fast
you wanted to happen fast you want it to
happen fast and now and then one day as
a comedian as a musician as a writer you
get smacked
something happens a situation not that
you uh we get smacked in the face but
you get smacked
something happens
and that'll teach you to slow it down a
bit
slow it down listen to what's going on
understand what's going on instead of
talking listening if you're a [__]
fresh out of college and you're around
two guys that make films and they've
made films before what are you talking
about why are you even talking
listen you know God Gave You ears not to
[__] talk with to listen and I love
that gift when I started the podcast I
didn't want video we never won a video
and I tell you why because I wanted
people to get back to listening again I
loved the the concept of listening I
grew up listening you know I listened to
albums I listened to Richard Pryor I
listened to [__] you listened okay
I don't think
people put that time in they want too
much up front them as soon as they get
into something and they get going they
want too much and they they don't
understand
and that's why I hate when Comics
weren't ready go to Los Angeles
and I know you're saying Joey why not
I'll tell you why because you're around
people that are talking a high level
game that what your game is
and what will happen it'll make you rush
like I want to get there I want to get
that well you don't understand that
these two guys are saying this [__] have
been at it for 20 [__] years
so we get [__] ahead of ourselves and
that's okay guys guys I did it everybody
does it but once you realize it's a
journey
you slow it down you pay attention and
you listen
I feel in today's world I felt this 15
years ago that people weren't listening
anymore
it's like when people put a special out
Netflix or HBO it's always an hour
special what are they finding out
through algorithms
people don't watch a whole lot I'm sorry
people watch
28 minutes and shut it down the kid
calls them the UPS is at the door plus
listen if the special is that
interesting to them
UPS won't be at the door they don't give
a [__] who's at the door but after 20
minutes you're sitting there and it kind
of gets scaled so that's why people have
cut down
that that's why Netflix jumped into
15-minute specials that's why now these
Comics that are doing their own
marketing watch what they're doing
they're not putting up our specials on a
[__] it's all about the clip today
it's about the 10 minute clip the eight
minute clip people want to see
everything that's why I tell all these
young comments I can't wait to get a
special for what do you think is going
to happen
were bombarded with specials the best
thing you could do as a young comic is
every eight weeks put together a goal
that you're gonna put seven minutes up a
seven minute video
and let me tell you something like I've
said before in the old times when I got
into comedy the only exposure you had
was from seven to ten or Eleven on the
news when the news came if you were an
actor if you did a sitcom that's the
only thing now
you're on the stage 24 hours a day when
people go into work at nine when people
are working from home and they put that
[__] rock on the mouse to let the
employee know they're watching or
whatever the [__] people do and then
they got the iPad they're watching stand
up or they're watching Clips so listen
to podcasts or
but it's all in the [__] short realm
but we got to off to the to the room to
talk here with [__] listening and
stuff like that
it's always a play like if somebody if
you want to be a mechanic okay if you
grow up [__] working on cars with
your dad your uncle whatever the [__]
and one day you go I want to be a
mechanic
and you go to uh
training or something like that the
first [__]
you don't go into that place as a
[__] mechanic you go in there as a
mechanics Helper and let's pray that you
have a good mechanic that you could
apprent this from
just and he's going to teach you a few
things you're going to watch the other
mechanics and learn
that's why I always like the concept of
The Comedy Store
she considered a university it was a
four-year program and for a guy like me
it was a 10-year program
it really was a 10-year program because
I got in there in 97 and I stayed in
there all the way to about 2006 until
the ship went down and then I took a
seven year Gap and then I went back
there again but my Prime education with
those 10 [__] years those 10 years
with Mitzi in that store made me a
[__] killer and it was not only
because I was performing but because I
was performing with higher level
comedians I was in there with Bill Burr
and [__] Paul Mooney and [__]
Eddie Griffin and Rogan and you know it
was a back then it was the difference in
the comments that are now
but being around that level of Comedy
picks you up you'll learn it's like
you know what's the guitar player from
ZZ Top
that dude was like uh somebody's guitar
player Oh Hendricks he was yeah he was a
14 year old with [__] Hendricks
nobody talked to him then now he's
[__] in you know she's got legs he's
got a beard you know what I'm saying
uh the singer the guitar player from
Journey Neil Sean [__] playing the
band when he was 15 for Steve one of
those [__] [__] he was in
the band he just did and what do you
think do you think people talked to him
when he was 15 in the band like every
time he raised his hand like kid shut
the [__] up you don't even you don't
even have hair on your dick Shut the
[__] up are you doing the are you
drinking tonight no shut the [__] up go
back to your room and do homework
but eventually from learning keeping his
mouth shut that's what you become what
you are today so when I see Eleanor oh
when I see [__] uh
Lee like Lee really impressed the [__]
out of me Saturday night he really
did and I tell people all the time that
the pieces start coming together you
know and now Leo go up to Boston Lee's
had it Lee is in LA right now today and
he's got like 20 spots this week he's
going back to Hell he's doing
Bakersfield and [__] leads into it so
all those years on that podcast
listening listening taking Edibles us
making him pass out and see the devil
and go to Mars at least I had not a
space all that through all that [__]
he was still listening and
Saturday night was the [__] pound I'm
very proud of him I'm very uh happy that
this is because we had lunch or we had
we ate something here Friday night with
my wife and we're talking he goes I
really want to give stand up a chance
and I was
Hey listen man whatever the [__] you
want to do you know in this life
whatever you want to do you can do it
if and he told me why he goes I really
want to get the same reason I tell
people all the time
the reason why I went back to Jujitsu
the first time I learned that I was okay
but I felt I didn't do any justice and
this time I'm going in there the right
way and that's the same thing he said he
goes I didn't think I was doing it right
with the fourth wall and all the
[__] because I just didn't think I
was doing it right so I just want to do
it again and see where it takes me he
goes I don't want to be 50 and say to
myself I didn't [__] do this so I
wish him more luck in the world than uh
it was just a great show Sarah weinchek
was funny as [__] she hit me with a
[__] joke that was so funny
and uh
Kim was [__] tremendous Kim I could
you know I asked him last night how long
have I known her and she goes 11 years
and I go Kim when I met you
it was just a young girl with [__]
ponytails you know cracking jokes at the
store
you know knocking [__] out with
at the uh at the rap battle she's like
the rap battle Championship right roast
battle rap battle I don't even [__]
know
and uh you watch these girls like you
see him at the store and you say hello
and you talk to them and you chit chat
with them and I told him to a face last
night uh Kim it's
great to see that you've grown up into a
woman I I've watched you you know
there's another girl that when I first
got to the store in 97 she was a young
kid
Kyra sultanovich [__] great comic
Tonight Show
you know I know Kira when she was just a
young girl
and then you know things I stopped going
to the store I didn't see her for years
and the next time I saw Kyra sultanovich
she had kids and she was [__]
beautiful
she had grown into a [__] woman to
see that is [__] tremendous to see
them 10 years later and then she's got a
boyfriend and she's doing great her
comedy was off the chain and guys I know
I'm a little partial of Sarah winechak
and uh Kim's podcast
it's great I think it's really [__]
great I I love watching it I said it on
stage Saturday night that whenever I
watch that podcast it's like listening
to the song Girls Just Want to Have Fun
by Cindy law but when that [__] song
first came out I wanted to kill Cyndi
Lauper if I would have saw on the street
I would have pulled the [__] pink
hair out of her head because I was 21 I
was a half a fat Catholic kid I didn't
want girls to have fun you know what I'm
saying I wanna I Wanna Marry I want to
have kids with you I don't need you down
Seaside [__] 20 guys or something and
coming back and saying you love me I
don't need that [__] I don't need that
[__] in my life you know you're [__]
stupid when you're 21. so I hated that
[__] song but then the years went by
I had a daughter and now I see girls and
I'm like I love when girls are just out
there [__] around not giving a [__]
and Kim and Sarah are [__] doing that
and I love that podcast they say some
[__] on there that is wrong but it's
funny at the same time and you know when
you have girl women in your life you got
to support them and that's it was great
it was just [__] great but something
really weird happened last night
because I asked Mike we're driving into
the city last night there was a lot of
traffic on the three
and Route 3 is the root that tation to
the Lincoln Tunnel past McKinley School
where I went to school past [__] my
mother's bar in Union City and then
but people were stopping last night to
take a picture of the full moon
on the [__] highway people were
getting out of their car stuck in bumper
to bumping traffic getting out of their
[__] car
and taking pictures of the full moon and
I never and I said to myself as I was
going in there I go
this is a [__] super full moon
tonight
I wonder what the city has to offer
tonight I just I didn't even think about
nothing I just said to myself I wonder
what the city has to offer tonight
because New York City is always a
[__] party never mind with a full
moon and the weather was beautiful last
night it was [__] great out last
night
get into the [__] City last night I
mean we got there early early everything
worked out
we got in there okay the food was great
laughing gas I want to thank you guys
for [__] coming out I want to thank
the Philly guys the silly guys with the
what's the name of the company
be [__] tremendous oh my God
these things last night these [__]
sillies
uh psychedelic mushroom these gummies oh
my God
I want to thank them for sending out a
bag to give out to my friends in New
York they [__] loved it
and let me tell you something about this
company I love them because they're
doing like every time I post one of
their pictures there's always these
Geniuses on Twitter oh my God they're
not suicide shut the [__] up and we
don't give a [__] what you got to say go
get into an argument with somebody on
Instagram or some [__] about what your
thoughts are I really don't care this is
a tremendous company and I've said it 20
[__] times I wish I could invest in
them because all these people micro
dosing this is the easiest way to
[__] get it done they taste good I
was [__] up last night guys I must
have ate three or four of them and at
one point I looked at Lee in the [__]
backseat of the car and I'm like wow Lee
looks [__] now you already it was a no
I'm starting to see things and I swear
to God he didn't say that in 10 minutes
later I was looking at a fence and the
grass was moving in front of it and the
[__] was moving over I just looked my
[__] head straight I know you
[__] seen the video I put up on
Instagram after the show of us going
home
with the [__] chicks with the little
Indian things that were Puerto Ricans
shaking their ass on the Street New York
City was in full effect last night when
we got out of there
I got the [__] see I love it I love
when I see the city like that it was so
funny because the one video I was asking
people hey you thinking of a covered
booster you're thinking of a cut to free
Met tickets for a covert booster
millions of people on the street people
were looking at me like corporate
booster I even said free Met tickets for
tomorrow night's game and a covert
booster people are like [__] you nobody
was staying right away Instagram put on
the bottom covert information you know
the whole thing but there were some
Puerto Rican chick shaking their ass oh
my God they were [__] tremendous but
for some reason there was a lot of
people walking around with little
feathers on last night did you see that
last night like when we were walking out
I don't know what type of Indians they
were I don't know if they were [__]
celebrating
on indigenous day
[__] Monday but uh
I love I love New York City I I you know
there's certain people listen I'm too
old for that City right now but when I
was 20 21 I was over in that mess
every [__] night and I loved it I
love all that craziness it's just that
I'm [__] too old now but let me tell
you what happened last night just so you
guys know
listen guys we're not in good shape at
all and I'm and I keep seeing this
and I keep telling people about it every
[__] weekend people are acting up on
planes I just saw something with cruise
ships did you see this my cruise ships
are now gonna find you 500 bucks take
you off the [__] thing and you're
gonna pay for your helicopter ride off
the [__] thing that's it's 6 000 from
Jersey to Long Island I can't imagine if
you're in [__] Mexico what they're
gonna bang you have to come get you on a
ship
and again I keep saying this and saying
this and
you know the thing that happened at the
Hollywood Bowl with Dave Chappelle and
and
you know I don't know what's going on in
the world people are just not happy to
me I know what's going on and the
problem is
that we were indoors for too [__]
long we got too much crazy information
thrown our way
and people just not handling this [__]
guys I had a [__] headache for two
[__] years I didn't know what was
going on with me but I understood I
wasn't right and I got some [__] help
for it
but I think people are walking around
thinking hey this is great I knew a guy
for 10 years I've seen this guy in La
sweetheart of a guy
has a podcast nice comedian kid
you know for years every time I saw him
he was very neat nice car ever since the
pandemic every time I see him now it's
like he gets up in the morning doesn't
wash his hair
like you know when you get up in the
morning you comb your hair you get this
guy probably brushes his teeth and
doesn't [__] wash his hair and I'm
looking at this guy why didn't he I saw
a tape of the stand up and this ain't
the same guy I used to see all the time
and you could tell where uh
people are just something's going on man
and last night I don't know if you guys
know this I saw it this morning
that at Uncle Vinnie's in Jersey where I
usually perform some guy through a
[__] can
some girl girl Ariel on stage a comedian
girl now I love Dino and I love Vinnie
and they do great job down there with
security and stuff like that I've never
had a problem down there
but I saw the videotape this morning and
it's you know she's talking about what I
tell you [__] not to talk about
stage
and it's politics you know she got into
the Biden Trump thing and somebody asked
her who she voted for and then 10
minutes later she gets a can thrown at
him again
I'm from the school that for me it's not
worth talking about politics or religion
because I don't know enough about
politics from time to time after a
religious fact up there that I remember
from [__] you know Catholic school or
something like that
but at the end of the day she gets a can
thrown at him it hits the [__] wall
when she goes to bend over now
from the other side of that perspective
if I didn't put my hands on you or I
didn't insult Mike's wife or Mike
there's no reason why Mike should be
throwing a [__] can at me ever
even if I'm up here saying that I want
Nixon for President Nixon's making a
comeback
there's no [__] reason why you should
throw a [__] can at me okay no reason
at all you know so I just saw a little
bit of the of the stuff on Twitter
and I'm sure the guy's gonna get
arrested today or whatever some [__]
white trash dude you know it's the same
[__] all over
but then on my show last night in the
city we had a little [__] problem
last night
and I didn't catch it until I got off
stage
when I got on stage there was a little
commotion going on and uh
one of the dog guys and the manager came
to me and they go can you go outside and
speak to Kim
uh she's very upset I thought I had said
something and I didn't I spoke to Kim I
gave her a hug we we talked but I didn't
know what was going on and when I go
outside
she's upset you know she's uh visibly
upset she's crying like what happened
she goes when she got off stage some guy
grabbed a [__] [__] and uh Kim
is you know not the kind of girl that
you're gonna grab a [__] and get a free
[__] swap at it
and she did what any woman would do she
went and spoke to security and said this
guy so they went looking for the guy
and they couldn't find the guy so I
guess a couple minutes later
Sarah uh Sarah can confront to them and
the guy goes yeah I grabbed your [__]
go [__] you something he was bragging
about it
and she got pissed off and she went
outside looking for him and the guy was
already done like three quarters still
winning I guess Kim went out there and
I don't know what happened after that he
fell you know what I'm saying things
were not good he ended up on the floor
and uh
Kim handled the [__] business the way
a woman's supposed to that's
guys that's it you know
and uh everybody hugged them we were all
happy and then I woke up this morning
and they were talking about and Kim
posted a [__] thing next time
somebody grabs a [__] she's gonna shoot
him she's packing from now on and I had
guys I've seen him in Action a few times
uh I saw Kim yelling at some dude once
on Sunset Strip Kim is not
the type of person to [__] with like in
that sense you know Kim's got a great
personality and she beautiful and she's
funny but she's not your typical La
[__] chick you know and for me my
dick got hard my dick got hard when I
heard that Kim did this and I'll tell
you why but before I tell you about a
word for my [__] sponsor Jack
the podcast is sponsored by better help
listen sometimes you can fix it on a
problem for so long that you don't take
the time to find the solution I got the
same [__] problems but when you learn
how to find your Solutions there's no
better feeling a therapist can help you
become a better Problem Solver and make
it easier to accomplish your goals
that's why I'm talking to you about
Better Health I've been with better
health for about a year now and they've
broke it down for me Dana has given me
some exercises to do when things get
danged and I'm living a way better life
for you who don't know it better help
there's online therapy that offers video
phone and chat therapy sessions you
could choose not to see anybody and it's
more affordable than in person therapy
you're not going to find a personal
therapist to see you face to face right
now with better help I can have you
talking to somebody in two days so when
you want to be a better Problem Solver
the therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com DS again visit
betterhelp.com Diaz and get 10 off your
first month that's betterhelp.com
Diaz and now back to the Joint all right
you bad [__] I had to trick you
on that one don't forget if you haven't
mental health issues like we spoke about
in the podcast better help is always
there for you they helped me out they
taught me how to do the coping skills
and whatnot and here we are today I
still got a lot of [__] problems but
I don't have if I had 200 problems now I
got 99 of them you understand me so I'm
101 taking care of that's a lot better
so
uh a couple years ago maybe 10 years ago
a friend of mine called me a girl and
she goes I have a problem
and I go I was doing uh New Year's with
this comic and he was drunk and at the
end of the night he grabbed my [__] and
I didn't know what to say and
I kind of I don't know I kind of was
like
I'll talk to the guy and she was like no
I'm gonna do it myself and I guess she
cornered the guy and I never spoke again
and I never saw the [__] idiot again
and
guys listen
I treat life the way I treat life prison
whatever it's all the same in my world
okay
if people it's like my daughter some kid
at school kept banging her arm with a
pencil
I go to this it hurt your mercy she goes
no but why does he have to do it I go
listen don't [__] ask me
tell him
tell him what the [__] is going on stop
with the pencil and I guess Mercy went
in there she was scared that she was
going to get in trouble and that we
would be mad at her if she stuck up for
herself and I go never
she went in there now the kid don't
[__] hit it with the pencil I told
her to say a couple things to him a
certain way and now the kid sits too
behind and I go he hasn't bothered you
not at all and you know when you're a
woman in today's [__] society guys
you got two options of everything
you got the option to take that all
these other woman took all these me too
women took and all these victims
somebody grabbed my [__] it's wrong
what am I gonna do
and that's all great and dandy but
that's not going to work anymore guys we
got to take this back to [__] old
school okay
it's like anything else happens you have
to stop [__] in the beginning
like the way they should have stopped
Hitler at Munich you have to stop people
in the beginning grab them whatever say
listen I don't appreciate that this is
what and they'll either go for it or not
and the next time you have a decision to
make
and I understand these things you know
when you go to prison what's the word on
the street when you walk into prison you
don't want to get your balls busted no
as soon as you hit the cafeteria look
for the biggest dude with the most
tattoos and hit them in the head with
the [__] Sandwich Tray you're not
gonna go to jail you're already in jail
you're already in jail but if you hit
him even if the guy beats the [__] out
of you you go down swinging and people
will go dog don't [__] with that
[__] hit that dude with the
lunch train ahead that time that God
that episode goes a long time and that's
why I told my daughter that day ago if
they start busting your balls now in the
fourth grade and you don't [__] take
control of this [__] by the seventh
grade they're really going to be busting
your balls and by the time you're a
sophomore they're going to eat up
they're going to eat you the [__] up you
don't want that you know in our society
we had [__] [__] kids that [__]
with you and you hit them with The
Lunchbox and they move the [__] on all
of a sudden in today's society they're
called bullies we've done we've we've
created like this big uh bad wolf for
kids you getting bullied no some kids
just confused you got to teach your son
how to [__] take it to the next level
so he this doesn't continue to happen
when three goofy kids are like ooh that
kid's a nerd you know we should [__]
put a frog in his lunch box one of those
[__] are gonna go you know what
that dude's a purple belt jiu jitsu
and I'm not in the mood to have my
shoulder dislocated not right now I got
a big [__] uh what's that game with
the stick they playing whatever these
little [__] yeah Polo whatever the [__]
they play you know real [__]
are playing basketball baseball and
[__] tackle football okay
so
that's how you create your life with me
I'm not a tough guy I'm not a tough guy
whatsoever I don't have no fighting
skills at all
but I have no problem hanging in the
head with a [__] iPhone
I have no problem putting the gun put in
your [__] mouth and put you in a
trunk in the car I've done it before I
got no problems with these things these
are who I are because this is who I am
because I didn't like getting bullied or
I didn't like people [__] with me you
stop people right there and you say hey
you can't do this no more this ain't
gonna work no more and if it's done
again people said it to me for years I
had a guy who told me one time the next
time you [__] with me on the coke we're
gonna box we're gonna box with a knife
we're gonna stab each other to death did
I [__] with him again no because he came
to me like a gentleman and he spoke to
me from the [__] heart so what Kim
did last night was tremendous because
now the word gets out she's not one of
these you know Harvey Weinstein chicks
well he no he went to the hotel room you
did the movie now you want to complain
that Harvey want to [__] you in the ass
too late
what the [__] is wrong with you people
and this is why I like this [__] see for
years I didn't tell my mother's story
for years how embarrassing is that you
know your mother stabbed somebody you
don't ever want to repeat that story to
anybody I was embarrassed for [__]
years about that story but then I
thought about it and I thought about how
my mother raised me all those years like
when I was a kid at the playground when
I was when I first came from Cuba to New
York I didn't know any English so my
mother would give me instructions in
Spanish you haven't listened to the UFC
and the coaches are yelling like punch
them take them down put the Lego my mom
would just make little noise like
and then when I look she'd go
like
means touch them
means hard and for years I had a [__]
attack on my mother's whims that's
horrible when your mom sends you to
fight somebody because what do you tell
your mom no he's bigger than me no you
gotta [__] put your head down and go
in there and wrestle or fight and that's
how my mom raised me for a reason I was
so proud of my mother years later when I
found out that some guy was raping her
[__] sister and that my mom went
looking for her younger sister when she
found that she was getting raped by some
guy my mom broke a [__] vodka bottle
or some bottle stabbed them their back
threw it three [__] times
to me that's a beautiful [__] thing
and guess what that reputation followed
up from Cuba
all the way to the United States no but
my mom used to bartender bar by herself
till three in the morning in a in a
business that's mostly populated by
[__] men bartending on a Wednesday
night at 2 30 in the morning nobody
wants to leave a woman in a bar by
herself at 2 30 in the morning my mom
did it I knew she had a big knife back
there and I knew she had a [__]
shotgun back there like a double barrel
that you would always look at the
[__] bullets and [__] you know and I
would never [__] put a pastor I
always knew she could [__] shoot
somebody because when I was a kid before
I was even born she killed somebody that
was a natural [__] reaction that's
the reaction women have to have in
today's [__] what do you keep saying
Bikram molested man
Harvey Weinstein touched me he groped me
last week constant woof every day these
girls cry every day
but they want a TV show they didn't cry
when they're on that TV show because
they want to lose a TV show they're
gonna lose their little twenty thousand
dollars a week and they can't tell their
friends it's not cool to be TV so they
learn how to live with it while they're
taking the 25 000 a week they don't mind
that the guy says ooh I like your
[__] little Asian ass or you know he
grabs a [__] or whatever and then after
the [__] TV TV series is gone now I
gotta feel bad for constant woo because
she [__] got molested you know enough
enough where were you when you were
cashing the checks and having a good
time at [__] ABC parties you didn't
complain that one [__] time constant
woo so what the [__] are you talking
about by the time the show is over she
put a tweet out saying that thank God my
show got canceled then she got [__]
backlash and then she had to come up
with that story like you don't know what
was happening to me at the time
hello hello so whatever
it's just [__] you know you sit here
and you watch this [__] on a [__]
daily basis and you're like what are
these people [__] talking about
you know what are these I'm so sick and
tired of the sexual [__] [__] but
then you got a girl like that like
[__] Saturday night that handles your
own business
so in my world
my dick was [__] hard last night I
don't give a [__] if a girl bust you in
the head with a [__] bottle every
time you [__] touch her and I gotta
be honest with you guys
this is how I'm raising my daughter
this is how you have to raise your
children because people of out of their
[__] minds and they will try to
[__] uh [__] with you from every
direction you're like what is the sense
of this
what is your [__] point
I mean
guys I'm a [__] pig
I've always been a [__] pig
but I've never dreamed I'm just going up
to a girl and grabbing a [__] monkey
and you guys know I'm [__] nuts but
nobody at the store or anywhere I can
ever go in fact I had a situation
right before my daughter was born
and Redman and I discussed it for a long
time because Red Band the girl passed
away you know God Rest his soul she had
a troubled
it was a real troubled life and I got
pieces of it uh
before she asked herself she was very
sweet
but in 2012
I took the month of December off
to be close to my wife in case somebody
called you know water broke
she was scheduled for the [__] 13 uh
for January
but I was always hoping for the tax
break you know for December so I kept
you know thinking positively and I'm
like she's gonna have to she'll have the
kid December 28th whatever
that never happened
so I scheduled these [__] shows at
flappers
and it's with Jim Jefferies
and Jim was great we had a great time
but Friday night I get them it's me and
Jim
and a girl comes in and she goes hi my
name is Sarah and
I uh from the social media coordinator
or something you know
the time it's 2012. who the [__]
knows what social media coordinator is
you know I asked her what she did she
takes pictures and she's cute and she's
young
and that's it I thought should I thank
her and thank you for coming in the room
she goes drink whatever you want there's
you who's there Flappers will always put
Yoo-hoos in the refrigerator which is
pretty [__] cool
so I go up Jim Jeffries goes up I go
home
you know I don't drink I don't go to the
bar
the next [__] night I go into
flappers
I sign in I tell Barb I'm there I go in
the back I give Jim a hug
and boom we're doing our show and I
figure this night let me stay around and
watch Jim you know it's Saturday night
it's an early show I got nowhere to go
so I'm watching Jim and the social media
coordinator
comes in Taps me on the shoulder
and she goes hey man can I talk to you
for a second yeah what's up
and she goes I'm not really happy with
you
I go whoa
you just met me last night did I say a
joke on stage remember maybe I offended
you which I don't give a [__] anyway
you know she goes no no no no when we
were at the bar last night you grabbed
my [__]
and I go what uh the whole world I
pulled over to the side I go what the
[__] are you talking what what are you
saying
she goes last night after the show we
were all at the bar and you grabbed my
[__] and I go
drew it was me and she goes positive I
didn't say anything because I go no no
stop right there I go first of all
I left right after my set last night
what are you talking about
and she looked at me
I go yeah
and then right there the show was over
and Jim Jefferies was walking towards
mango Jim you got a minute I go did I
stay here last night maybe I'm missing
maybe the edible is too strong
maybe I'm missing something he goes no
in fact you left before right he goes
you went right from your car right from
the stage to your car that's that's what
Joey does if it's not my show what am I
doing what am I doing I got weed and
Edibles at the house I go dog at those
clubs when I used to go to Flappers I
would go and he wasn't kidding because
you go in the Green Room you go around
the back there and right back there you
don't have to go through the front you
slip out to the back and you're right
there in the parking garage so she just
looked at us
she just looked at the both of us and I
go it's okay she just thought that I
left a jacket here or some
and I go yeah I don't know
what you're talking about and I go it's
not really cool
and then she left I went to the back and
talked to Jim and as I got paid she came
back and she goes I'm really sorry
I'm really sorry I must have been really
drunk last night and I'm like
I'm gonna accept your apology
this is two thousand [__] 12.
nothing was really going on in my career
the podcast was going a little bit I was
doing some dates I go I'm gonna accept
your apology
but you really
have to be [__] careful with this
like I'm [__] it like I was insulted
like I'm like
this is not good this is a [__]
completely
false false false allegation to a
hundred percent
and the girl was like I understand you
know it won't happen again I go if
you're drinking like this and this is
like you're getting into this career
this is not this is not going to work
because you will get raped if you're
that drunk you're with a bunch of crazy
comedians that something bad will happen
if you don't remember I didn't see her
again we she apologized she apologized
she apologized I didn't see her again
then I go to the store one night and
there she is
he quit Flappers and now she was working
at the store
and we spoke and we became friends after
that and uh you know she went on to
cause other problems at the store and
whatnot but I'm not forget talking to
Red Man and red bands
said dog she kind of did the same thing
to me one night
so when I saw her at the store I stayed
away from her for a while just because
I can't have this I can't have somebody
accuse you of something because they
were drunk how the [__] are you accusing
me of grabbing your [__] when I wasn't
even there
that's just not [__] good at all so
I uh later on in life we became friends
and then this last year she passed away
so there was other problems there that
were looming you know as I got to Noah
she lost one of her boyfriends I mean it
was just a hard life for her and comedy
was all she had so when she made the
allegation I mean I was [__] floored
I'm like
at that time I was just trying to
[__] do comedy and trying to start
headlining and trying to really [__]
put it together and I'm like this is the
last thing I need in my life so
it bothered me for a while like I said
we became friends later on I think two
years ago before the pandemic
uh I bumped into it at the store and I'm
like did anybody grab your [__] tonight
it became like a joke you know we
giggled about it but there's the [__]
that happens every once in a while you
know can you imagine not grabbing
somebody's ass and getting in trouble
for this [__]
so after that I was like wow I would
never be [__] cool with this [__] but
I'm really happy that Kim handled it
like she did
I'm happy that uh
it's all [__] working out guys I I
couldn't be any happier in my life this
is exactly how I wanted it it's very
slow paced
I pick and choose what the [__] I want
to do and
I'm just trying to be a better man all
around and be a bit better Dad better
friend that's all I want to do right now
I'll take the [__] hits as they come
in you know I'll look at the shows I
don't want to get any planes but I'm
really happy that I took this residency
in the city and I'm really happy that
I'm doing stand up at the rate where I'm
having fun again
you know I just wanted to have fun guys
when a great man once told me when you
when you get into comedy is because you
don't want to have a job and I can live
with that I never wanted to have a job I
could understand that but
um
you still have to [__] justify
something you know
if it stand up was becoming a [__]
chore for me I gotta be honest here it
was becoming a chore for me it was just
too much it was too much getting thrown
at you you know the game changed a lot
over the years and I just had to get and
guys are still doing it I'm really happy
from it you know they're younger they
got fresher legs I'm happy for all these
upcoming guys I'll support them in any
way I can
but this is a [__] Paradise for me I
always wanted at this age for me to back
up a little from acting uh back up a
little from stand up and for the acting
to increase a little bit not a little
bit more
I remember last week we were talking
about the Hulu Pro uh the [__]
project the pilot blah blah blah I had
to go over that couldn't go to his
wedding and I [__] hated that whole
thing that whole process because they
weren't communicating with me boom that
went out the [__] window Friday I
auditioned for Law and Order organized
crime I got a good shot at that
and tomorrow guys is my [__] greatest
day ever because I get to read with
Robert De Niro tomorrow now I know that
I've told you guys about other instances
when I got to an audition and when I
walked in the room either John Travolta
was there or [__] the guy from It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia I've had
those situations where the actor is in
the [__] room
but you're not prepped for it and you
[__] your pants snatch a dog you [__]
your pants [__] okay you'll [__] your
[__] pants I don't give a [__] who
you are when you walk in then Travolta
is looking at you with those Scientology
eyes and he's
looking at you like you're a masseuse
you [__] and you're looking to read with
him and nah it's all a joke but it's
kind of [__] intimidating and uh
this was great when I got the call last
week that I was going to do a live call
back with him
to direct the the producers and the
[__] casting director a little for a
little bit I got a little nervous but
then I'm like this is great because I'm
prepared again it's not like I'm going
in there and reading with a reader and
while I'm walking in there and I see
Robert De Niro you know [__] Irishman
I'm going in there and I know I'm gonna
go in there and read with him so
I'm reading uh instead of two one scene
I'm reading two scenes
I'm meeting him in a fancy [__] hotel
valet parking is ninety dollars
in the city when I called and they were
like yeah we have how much
50 last night that's not bad but 95.
that's [__] crazy no you got to give
the guy a tip the pool get the poor
little Mexican guys running back and
forth dodging [__] cars
so uh yeah this week's gonna be a good
week for me I'm excited that this is
happening I'm prepared which is the most
important you know what do they say
preparation
and whatever equals luck I don't know
everybody's always a [__] philosopher
so uh yeah it's gonna be a [__] great
week guys hopefully we uh booked this
film
and we get one more good shot and a
great movie I get to make insurance and
uh nothing happens in my life you know
it all stays the [__] same this is
the best I am so grateful that at this
age I'm still being looked at for roles
I thought
I was all washed up for a while but I've
had six great auditions the last couple
weeks and uh
let's see what the [__] happens guys I
got nothing going on this week I'm
probably gonna go down to Uncle Vinnie's
and do a spot down there and see what's
going on
and that's all I got you bad
[__] it's going to be a great
week
we're two weeks away from Halloween I'm
still coming out as a big dick for
Halloween or a big black dick I'm gonna
dress up I don't [__] know I'm not
dressing up for Halloween I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna have a great time with
the [__] girls and uh
do the best that I can but guys it's
Monday I come to you on a Monday nice
short podcast Wednesday we have a guest
the podcast this week will be coming out
on Thursday so this week again we'll
have a Thursday uh
Morning podcast for you and that's it
and that's that [__] don't
forget you got Monday Night Football
tonight you got Las Vegas against
[__] uh who the [__] is playing
Las Vegas
[Music]
Kansas City it's going to be a great
week you got the Yankees you got
everything
so uh I love you [__] stay black
and we'll be back Wednesday Thursday
morning Tip Top will go to rock your
[__] world thank you for being here
have a great day now for a worth my
[__] sponsors Jack
all right I want to thank you
[__] on a beautiful Monday
morning but I want to thank Bluetooth
for sponsoring the podcast on a
beautiful Monday because there's nothing
scarier than not being able to perform
with you with your beautiful mate
Bluetooth is here to make your dick all
treat and no tricks you're like Joey
what's bluetooth it's an online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis in
chewable tablets all at a fraction of a
cost take the many time and be ready
when she's ready or he whatever you're
[__] doing these days listen I love
blue chew you can eat them on an empty
stomach you can bring them right along
with you and you're ready to go and it
gives you that boost of confidence when
you're gonna give somebody a stabbing of
Life the process is simple sign up at
Bluetooth consult with a licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online no doctor's office
no awkward conversations no long line at
the pharmacy Bluetooth tablets are made
in the USA and they're shipped
discreetly in a package if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform Bluetooth can help try
Bluetooth for free when using promo code
Joey just five dollars for shipping
bluetooth.com with Coach Joey for your
first month free do me a favor visit
bluetooth.com for more safety
information and I want to thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring The Joint the
joint is also brought to you you buy
better help this podcast is sponsored by
better help sometimes you just fixate on
a problem so long you can't take care of
it when you learn how to find your
Solutions there's no better feeling a
therapist can help you become a better
Problem Solver and even a better person
I've been with Bluetooth I've been with
the Monroe a better betterhelp.com now
for about a year Dana has done Miracles
with me she's helped me how to cope
teach me how to cope with different
situations that I was having a problem
with better help can also help you their
online therapy that offers video phone
and chat sessions you can choose not to
see anyone on camera or you could see
somebody and it's much more affordable
than in person therapy
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can help you there visit
bluetooth.com
Diaz again Bluetooth no
betterhelp.com DS
to get 10 off your first month that's
better
help.com slash Diaz and the joint is
also brought to you by it's Monday Night
Football [__] and DraftKings is
there the official sports betting part
of the NFL
Las Vegas against Kansas City tonight I
think the line is seven and the over and
under is 51. you got a tremendous game
and and you're lucky because everyone
can boost their winnings with DraftKings
stepped up same game ballets I like the
over tonight and to make things sweeter
you could throw down on a stepped up
same game probably the more legs you add
the more money you win and now you can
put in one per game day all season long
but download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app now use promo code Joey to get you
200 and free bets if your team wins when
you place a five dollar bet you build
your bankroll and now you're coming into
gambling [__] season when we can make
some money and it's not even gambling
it's fun that's called Joey only at
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details now go download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app or the
download the DraftKings fantasy app
you're gonna win some money either way
when you're pressing coach Joey I want
to thank Better Health I want to thank
DraftKings and I want to thank Bluetooth
importantly you guys for always having
my back stay black have a great day and
we'll see you cocksuck this Thursday
morning Tip Top Magoo
foreign